you're an adult you're in your 30s but
you you're able to access this childlike
side of yourself well it's more like I'm
able to sometimes access the adult side
of myself until you're mostly very
childish yeah I think so and we we still
play the you know oh I guess she said
the F word so I can say penis you know
one clears anything with me first
she's an I so I can say huh there's a
whole breather there's a whole system
here it's a bureaucracy but you said
penis you say penis all the time what
are you talking about I heard you say
penis like ten minutes before we go I
was singing penis warm-up I do before
the show it's how I prepare know what
question mine meth heads it's it's a
wait what is it there's a game well
there's a game I'm sure people know that
pain is game is the most United the
crowd has been all
it's important to us it's where you
strong my towns chapter of it sadly it's
yeah if you start saying it very quietly
in a public place and the rule is the
next person has to say it louder than
the person before until you're
practically screaming it in a public
place so if someone says it kind of loud
then you have to yeah right you have to
really good then in a restaurant that's
just sounded like you sneeze that didn't
exactly you're trying to do it in a
sneaky way yeah because you don't want
to be so embarrassed you restaurant
people don't want to hear the word penis
yelled out I don't know what restaurants
you're going to once I go to that's a
prerequisite for getting your meal sir
haven't you forgotten something
that was loud you stand up and scream
that while pointing at your bowl of soup
yeah there's a penis in my soup don't
tell the others they'll want one too
[Laughter]
it's the worst show on till I'm churning
butter on listen good god okay so I
don't know I'm not gonna hang with you
and your friends no we don't do that all
the time just most times yeah it's most
times okay
you